[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
aujourd'hui nous sommes à saint germain
en laye au musée départemental maurice
denis pour fêter la réouverture de cet
établissement voici le sommaire après
trois ans de travaux de rénovation le
musée maurice denis à saint germain les
accueille de nouveau du public nous
parlerons avec la directrice du musée
des changements et des expositions en
cours lors des journées du patrimoine la
ville à beauchêne au vésinet a rendu
hommage à joséphine baker qui sera
bientôt ans théo nous et c'était la
vraie artiste a passé 18 ans dans cette
demeure et puis enfin nous découvrirons
la nouvelle exposition à la bibliothèque
centrale de versailles à visiter
jusqu'au 11 décembre
[Musique]
nous sommes dans le jardin du musée
départemental maurice denis à saint
germain en laye après trois ans de
rénovation celui-ci rouvre ses portes
pour les journées du patrimoine
marine marie aline charrier bonjour
bonjour vous êtes la directrice du musée
maurice denis alors peut-être avant de
parler des de la rénovation est ce que
vous pouvez m'expliquer qui était
maurice denis alors maurice denis était
un peintre et théoricien aux sources de
l'art moderne et il a fondé avec
quelques autres artistes un mouvement
que l'on appelle les nabis les prophètes
qui dont la destination première on va
dire était de faire rentrer le décor
dans la vie quotidienne et nous sommes
ici dans le jardin comme vous l'avez dit
mais avec en arrière fond le bâtiment
qui était en fait sa résidence sa
demeure familiale est également
le dernier grand atelier qu'il a occupés
jusqu'à la fin de sa vie il a vécu à
saint germain la quasi-totalité de sa
vie et les 30 dernières années dans
cette propriété alors maintenant on va
parler peut-être de cette rénovation
trois ans de travaux finalement quels
sont les changements que peut-on voir
alors trois ans de travaux mais aussi
accompagné d'autres réaménagements c'est
à dire que notre premier gros chantier a
été de pouvoir sortir les oeuvres du
musée de façon justement à ce que les
travaux puissent avoir lieu dans ce
bâtiment et donc nous avons créé avec le
département des yvelines des nouveaux
locaux de réserve et nous avons préparé
la totalité de collection à leur
transfert vers ce nouveau ce nouveau
site pour que les travaux puissent
commencer donc ça c'était vraiment notre
premier gros chantier et ensuite on a
engagé cette première phase de travaux
de rénovation donc on a mis en
accessibilité le site c'est à dire ses
abords immédiats mais aussi l'intérieur
puisque c'est assez paradoxal mais pour
accéder à la salle d'exposition du rez
de chaussée ici il faut monter et
descendre des marches voilà donc nous
avons un ascenseur une table élévatrice
donc la mise en accessibilité était
vraiment très importante on en a profité
aussi pour remplacer un certain nombre
d'organes technique puisque le musée a
quand même 40 ans d'existence un petit
peu plus aujourd'hui donc il était
important aussi de remettre un peu à
jour tous ces éléments techniques
fondamentaux on a remis en peinture les
salles d'exposition on a reçu l
éclairage
et on en a profité également pour
introduire dans le parcours de visite
pour la réouverture de nouveaux éléments
et finalement quelles sont les oeuvres
qu'on peut voir actuellement alors il y
en a beaucoup vous avez d'abord les
oeuvres qui sont en extérieur et
notamment sur la terrasse qui nous
surplombe nous accueillons des dépôts de
grandes sculptures en bronze d'antoine
bourdelle qui me sont prêtés par le
musée bourdelle de paris et à
l'intérieur du musée donc l'exposition
venant rêver que
nous allons pouvoir découvrir tout à
l'heure et trois nouvelles sculptures
donc un claude l1 roda et un mayol qui
lui a été installé dans le jardin est
justement vous parlez donc donné cette
nouvelle exposition maurice denis
bonheur rêver et regardez ce reportage
où vous y trouverez tous les détails
maurice denis bonheur rêver c'est le
titre de la nouvelle exposition du musée
départemental maurice denis c'est aussi
la première qui présente la vie du
peintre dans sa ville phare saint
germain en laye cette exposition fait
écho également à l'obtention du label
maison des illustres c'est vraiment
faire ressentir aux visiteurs l'esprit
du lieu puisque on est ici dans la
dernière maison de maurice denis et la
dernière partie de l'exposition est
consacrée aux années prieuré donc on a
des représentations de la maison de
maurice denis dans laquelle on se trouve
dans l'exposition l'exposition est
construite en quatre parties et parcourt
la vie de maurice denis au fil de ces
maisons dans chaque partie de
l'exposition est présentée un portrait
ou un autoportrait du peintre est ici
donc ce portrait bien connue de maurice
denis par par lacombe lacombe qui était
un des membres du groupe des nabis dont
maurice denis et l théoriciens et qui a
fait le buste de différents membres du
groupe sérusier qu'on présente dans la
première salle de l'exposition en bronze
une centaine d'oeuvres sont exposées
plusieurs proviennent des collections du
musée d'autres de collections privées
cette exposition retrace aussi
l'intimité de maurice denis on peut y
voir ses parents ses différentes maisons
et des portraits de famille comme celui
que par maurice denis en 1902 vraiment
le la femme qui a le plus été représenté
dans son oeuvre on la voit dans leur
intérieur 59 rue de mareil qui est un un
appartement juste à côté du musée on
voit mart avec trois de ses filles les
trois aînés et les trois petites est ce
qui est intéressant dans ce tableau
c'est d'abord la gamme de couleurs et
surtout l'évocation de l'intérieur de
maurice denis l'exposition occupe les
deux niveaux de présentation des salles
elle est visible jusqu'au 29 mai alors
marie aline charrier on vient de voir le
sujet finalement il n'y a pas que cette
exposition d'autres temps forts sont
également à prévoir tout à fait alors
j'en citerai trois 3 points principaux
tout d'abord une participation à la nuit
blanche
2 au 3 octobre prochain où l'on propose
aux visiteurs de découvrir mais d'une
façon un peu particulière le me juger
les plongées dans le noir donc chacun
sera équipé d'une lampe torche de façon
à pouvoir et découvrir les oeuvres mais
aussi découvrir le site de façon
vraiment singulière ça c'est le premier
temps fort voilà deuxième temps fort
nous avons la généreuse participation
d'eric emmanuel schmitt ça qui a accepté
d'être le parrain du 150e anniversaire
de la naissance de maurice denis et qui
viendra faire une conférence le 5
octobre ainsi qu'une séance de dédicaces
et pour finir le dernier temps fort je
dirais le mois du japon qui est prévu
sur le mois de janvier 2022 puisque les
labit donc maurice denis et le japonisme
était particulièrement important et donc
nous célébrons nous musée départemental
maurice denis le mois du japon le nouvel
an japonais avec une programmation très
riche surtout d'un durée du mois de
janvier 2022 et bien c'est noté on sera
là merci vos courses à rien d'avoir été
votre invité merci pour toutes ces
explications merci à vous
[Musique]
et on reste dans la ville de
saint-germain-en-laye la nouvelle saison
2021 2022 vue théâtre alexandre dumas et
lancée je vous donne quelques dates à
retenir avec d'abord la première édition
du festival saint germain en live du
mardi 5 au dimanche 10 octobre de
nombreux artistes se produiront sur la
scène du théâtre comme daniel auteuil
avec son spectacle musical inédit
déjeuner en l'air le mercredi 10
novembre à 20h45 venez applaudir
bérengère krief son nouveau spectacle
amour parlera de ce grand sujet toujours
avec humour et enfin la compagnie de
danse art move concept revient pour sa
6ème création intitulée à nos passes
mardi 7 décembre à 20h45 cette oeuvre
mélange danse hip hop ballet et circuit
le 30 novembre prochain joséphine baker
grande artiste américaine de music hall
sera pente et venise et à l'occasion des
journées du patrimoine la ville à
beauchêne au vésinet là où il ya résidé
pendant 18 ans propose de lui rendre
hommage regardez
ces de 1929 à 1947 que joséphine baker a
vécu dans cette demeure pour les
journées européennes du patrimoine la
villa beauchesne a ouvert ses portes ou
plutôt son extérieur des visites
commentées du parc et est organisée par
les membres de la société d'histoire du
vésinet c'est en 29 qu'ayant commencé à
avoir une certaine notoriété et certains
revenus elle a pu avec son mari de
l'époque acheté cette maison c'est
quelqu'un qui est venu habiter ici pour
être tranquille donc elle vivait au
milieu de ces animaux
un spectacle musical a eu lieu dans la
cour de la villa les visiteurs présents
ont pu également voir l'exposition
consacrée à la vie de joséphine baker
récemment j'ai lu un livre de raconter
sa vie donc j'ai découvert cette femme
que je connaissais très peu en fait et
voilà qu'on m'invite pas loin mais
c'était l'occasion de voir là où elle a
vécu un moment de sa vie dit c'est très
bien c'est super bien fait les guides
sont gentils en savent beaucoup donc
c'est agréable dans un cadre super
league grâce à la notoriété de cette
danseuse et meneuse de revue la ville du
vésinet bénéficie d'une attractivité
culturelle la célèbre artiste souvent
mis à l'honneur elle est mise en avant
où nous lui avons donné le nom son nom
sur une salle associative
nous avons prévu aussi de donner une
option sur une place dans un des
nouveaux quartiers que nous sommes en
train de construire durant la seconde
guerre mondiale joséphine baker s'engage
dans la résistance c'est donc grâce à
son service rendu pour la nation qu'elle
entrera au panthéon le 30 novembre
prochain ce sera la première habitants
du vésinet à être pente est honni zay
prenons la direction de versailles à
présent la bibliothèque centrale
accueillera jusqu'au 11 décembre
l'exposition la curiosité d'un prince
celle du comte d'artois beaucoup
d'objets rares sont à découvrir en
partenariat avec le musée quai branly
jacques chirac
une coiffe d'apparat des amériques un
pagne de guerriers ou encore le premier
masque en provenance du continent
africain voici quelques pièces parmi la
cinquantaine exposées à la bibliothèque
municipale de versailles ces pièces sont
une infime partie de la collection
amassée par charles 10 petit frère de
louis saez qui comprend plus de 500
objets la collection du comte d'artois
était une collection extraordinaire qui
était destiné à l'instruction des
dossiers ficelés duc d'angoulême et de
berry donc elle comprenait des
instruments de physique de chimie
beaucoup de spécimens naturaliste et
surtout une magnifique collection
d'objets du monde entier des objets qui
étaient perçus comme exotique mais
reflétant les us et coutumes des peuples
éloignés aujourd'hui la grande majorité
des pièces de cette collection est
stocké au musée du quai branly jacques
chirac la bibliothèque conserve tout de
même une quinzaine de pièces le lycée
hoche de versailles héberge lui aussi
une partie de la collection le lycée
hoche a hérité des collections d'objets
d'histoire naturelle
de l'ancien cabinet de curiosités du
comte d'artois et notamment celles qui
avaient été collectés
par fire qui est qui était un ancien
commis au bureau des colonies d'amérique
et si le compte était aussi attaché aux
amériques il faut rappeler que jusqu'en
1803 la louisiane étaient toujours une
colonie française ils ont donc rapporté
de nombreux objets de la tribu
amérindienne chaque cahot le projet
collaboratif avec la nation zhao est né
du souhait de valoriser ces pièces ou
qu'ils proviennent de leur territoire
ancestral dans le cas de cette
exposition l'exposition la curiosité
d'un prince est à visiter jusqu'au 11
décembre
et c'est la fin de ce set 8 culture
merci de nous avoir suivis rendez vous
la semaine prochaine dans un autre lieu
culturel yves binois bonne soirée sur tv
[Musique]